hello everyone and welcome to uh the
first game of the knockout section we'll
be checking out it's a hikaru nakamura
versus magnus carlsen and
for those of you who may not know these
are the pairings so
uh magnus will face hikaru uh geary will
face rajabo maxima sherlock
will face wesley so and fabi will face
yanni ponnishi
and this is a game that well ended very
abruptly and in a very interesting way
so without further ado let's check it
out and see
uh what's happening here already things
are getting very very exciting
so hikaru with the white pieces opens
with e4
that we have e5 by magnus knight of
three knights to c6 and
bishop to b5 so the rule lopez is on the
board
we have a6 morpheus defense and now
bishop to a4 with knight to f6
and castle so this is all uh very
standard stuff offering the four pawn
uh so black captures it uh we have d4
and now b5 chasing back the bishop with
bishop to b3 and the d5
now so this is all right very very
standard stuff
d captures on e5 and now just bishop to
e6 we have knight beat to d2
and now knight to c5 going after white
slide square bishop
we have c3 and now bishop to e7
uh we have bishop to c2 not allowing any
capture in the future also the bishop
will be very useful here
and now d4 so this has all been played
before nothing out of the ordinary
uh knights to b3 now uh reinforcing the
center also now
uh challenging the knight here so here d
captures on c3
knight captures with bishop captures and
now comes uh
uh bishop e4 so attacking this
knight here you can't really capture the
you could capture the queen so but then
you have to worry about something like
captures although this is not an issue
for black but here
hikaru just plays queen to d7 he defends
like this sorry magnus
and then now hikaru captures back with b
captures on c3 we have rooked the d8
and now queen to c2 and the both players
have played very quickly
uh this has all been played before we
have knight to e7 now remaneuvering the
knight and the bishop to g5 by hikaru
now clearing the
uh well the the open d file for his
rooks and here
uh there is a game where bishop to d5
was played uh but here we have
h6 and it is now only as a move 17 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see how hikaru reacts to this
h6 move uh he starts with rook after d1
of course now you attack the queen so
the queen has to move
and now after queen to c8 we have bishop
capture sunny seven
uh rook capture sunday one with check by
magnus rook captures and now
king captures on e7 and this is where
things really
start to go wrong here you have to
capture with the bishop
and allow this check simply bishop
bishop to c6 checking f8 and you
continue playing the game
magnus wanted to avoid all of this he
played king captures on e7 and now he
wants the castle artificially with rook
uh rook to d8 however here comes
knight to d4 and here it's very hard for
for magnus to even find the move because
it's a it's a really strong knight it
can always come to c6 if you capture it
then white has a very very strong center
this is this is basically
lost for black if white starts pushing
these pawns and another thing if you go
rook to d8 and then just knight to c6
check wins on the spot because now the
rook is attacked twice
so magnus really needs a move here uh
magnus plays
rook to e8 he still wants the castle
artificially but
hikaru does not allow it he plays bishop
to f3
now if magnus plays king to f8 now
hikaru could go queen to h7 and now
checked and this falls then the entire
position just falls apart
so magnus first needs to weaken his
position by playing g6 and now hikaru
just brings the queen back queen d2
nicely centralizing but again with tempo
as the h6 pawn is under attack
so here magnus goes bishop captures c
captures and bishop to g4
saying that okay now we trade here and
everything is going to be perfectly fine
my idea is that after the the bishops
are traded you cannot capture on h6
because your rook on d1 would be hanging
however here hikaru had a different idea
and he actually has a completely winning
idea so feel free to pause the video
here
and win the game for hikaru while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not doing anything with the bishop and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's d5
i know you all got that right uh because
you know d6 is coming and
also queen to see queen to be for check
is now possible and that's gonna win the
bishop so black can't really waste the
move
uh and play something like king 2f8 the
castle because this queen check
just wins the bishop uh simple as that
so here
after d5 magnus decided to play bishop
captures on f3 but now hikaru
doesn't react to this he just goes d6
with check because this was the plan all
along
and now you can't go to f8 yet again
because now d7 just wins the game
uh so magnus really wants to play king
to f8 for
for the entire game but hikaru simply
doesn't allow it so king to d7
and only now g captures on f3 saying
that
this is not possible because if you
capture this now
then we simply deliver this uh
discovered check and
once the king moves we just deliver
another check and pick up the rook so
magnus is completely helpless here we've
looked at e6 by magnus but now comes
rook to c1 threatening the uh the c7
pawn so
magnus pushes it to c5 queen to e3 with
a double attack on the pawn and now c4
but now hikaru just
jumps in with the queen queen to a7 with
check so
not really a lot of squares for the
black king king the e8 but now
rook to d1 now threatening again to win
the game like this
so queen d7 but now hikaru just plays a
queen to a8 with
check magnus has to block but now hikaru
just continues collecting pawns
uh queen captures on a6 and the
situation on the clock isn't that great
for magnus it's some three and a half
minutes for hikaru and a minute and a
half for magnus
uh so here uh we have uh uh king the f8
uh instead of uh this queen captures on
a6 i will just show a fun line the d7
wins on the spot but it's uh magnus is
like a minute on the clock you don't
really want to waste time calculating
this
i'm just going to show it because it's
really awesome point is that now the
king cannot move to f8 because the queen
hangs so you have to play this
and then comes queen to d5 and there's
no defense against queen to c5 uh if you
tried to hide the king
again king to f8 is impossible uh
because queen to c5 check and that's it
king g7
uh queen to c8 and that's it there's no
defense here the queen uh
either trades and then we get another
queen uh or you move the queen and then
white still gets another queen so
uh d7 was winning on the spot but hicaro
doesn't want to uh
waste his time calculating he just he
knows that that this is winning
that's just too many pawns for white so
king to f8 by magnus uh
is it possible now hikaru says not
really queen captures on b5
and there's really not much for magnus
to do now now hikaru created another
pass pawn
and that's just a really really tough
position queen to g5 would
check king to f1 and now comes rook
captures on e5 so magnus is able to
eliminate one of the past pawn one of
the pawns
uh but now comes uh a problem move well
not really a problem because he car
played this instantly
he played queen captures on e5 the move
from the thumbnail of course and now
he was in this position on move 36 that
magnus carlsen
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
if the queen is captured then hikaru
just continues with
d7 and there's no defense against d8 uh
he promotes to a queen
and that's it there are no tricks checks
or any sort of uh you know sneaky ideas
uh around so it makes sense to just
resign the game
uh whatever you play uh he just gets
another queen and a queen into the game
and that's it
uh so after this beautiful queen
captures on e5
uh magnus resigned and game one goes to
hikaru
so yeah hopefully this one will process
in time because i had some problems with
the previous video but uh what are you
going to do yeah you know not everything
can always
work properly so i will continue showing
this uh match uh i would like to thank
uh pratt
mahajan caleb ewing uh michael voska
ruben
virik and the dane scott for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing with the
coverage of this very nice event
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day